diesem
Haus nein
Gott oh
ja
ach das meinst du sehr
wild hey leute ihr merkt schon ich bin
nicht zu Hause bin bei meiner Freundin
die Katzen hat den heute haacken wir
einen catmom Adventskalender aus und sie
darf natürlich dabei sein sie hat
richtig Lust wir sind natürlich sehr
respektvoll du bist ja erfahrene Cat mom
seit wie vielen Jahren seit 9 Jahren
Romo ist neun m und den haben wir
seitdem er Baby ist und Susi ist sieben
die hatte am Montag Geburtstag am 201.11
ist sie nicht eine Straßenkatze ja sie
kommt aus dem Tierschutz woher kennt man
dann ihren Geburtstag das ist eine gute
Frage ich glaube den haben sie einfach
in den haustierausweis geschrieben
[Musik]
jetzt kriegen wir das was wir verdienen
so Spielzeug Nummer ein schon mal toll
ah ja na schauen wir mal was hier noch
drin ist ne wie findest du den Geruch
erstmal g ein kleines schmanal schon
täglich gesund belohn Leinöl Biotin und
Zink als erstes gibt so eine cheesepaste
oh die riecht lecker nach Käse einfach
so in der Mitte so ein Bub ja so ein
kleinen Bub
bei Käse ist eigentlich ein bisschen
wlerisch ched findet er ganz gut
Käse den gibt's nicht mehr W den gibt
nicht mehr gib nicht mehr
bisschen nicht zu nah ja ich glaube hat
200 € gekostet soll ich mal kurz dein
Handy holen ja oh hier ist der Kalender
spielen wir jetzt Youtuber wir spielen
jetzt
Youtuber vielen Dank für Ihre Bestellung
199999 200 € was sagt das als als
Katzenbesitzer für dich ja das scheint
Qualität zu sein
hoffentlich mehr brauchen sie halt auch
nicht
wow das hier alleine das ist perfekt das
müssen wir entsorgen das frisst Romo das
ist Plas damit spielter nicht das frisst
bin
aufgeregt dieses Video ist nicht
gesponsort ne bevor wir zu oft
herzenskatzen
oderat Adventskalender
oder und jetzt alle dieses Video ist
nicht gesponser jetzt
komm Türchen Nummer ein
oh
fantastisch süß süß es es fängt stark an
oh mein Gott ich sehe dich schon Backen
oh mein Gott ich sehe dich wirklich
Plätzchen backen und nur das ist
fantastisch oh das ist wirklich cool we
beides triff Weihnachten Cat mom ah humo
sucht schon das Türchen Nummer zwe ne
ich glaube da ist so Catnip Katzengras
mäßig was drin oh er wird geil auf den
Kalender aber das ist auch gut zu wissen
ne wenn das irgendwas ist worauf sie
super geil sind dann kannst du den ja
nicht so stehen haben ich bin ganz
begeistert von ihm muss ich sagen er
interagiert uns nie so gern mit Fremden
aber du bist ja nicht mehr fremd spel
hier wirklich
Youtuber t Nummer
Z oh ein cremesnack von Dr clauders was
ist creme meine ehemalige Kollegin würde
jetzt sagen schleckschlimppfe das ist
ein Leckerli und da muss man gucken SAS
gibt's Hal nicht oft ja genau das ist
einfach ein Snack das braucht man nicht
kann man aber also glaub ich Ken keine
katzenperson die keine Leckerlis in
petto hat also hier gebe ich mir aus der
Packung weil das ja lange ist morgen
weg was ist mit dir Spey
speckwurst Türchen Nummer D oh
ein spielzeugkissen mit Hundepfoten
drauf Hundepfoten ja das sind
Hundepfoten aber ich glaube das ist
Katzengras oh das sieht aber voll
selbstgemacht aus ne ja das hier sieht
sehr selbstgemacht aus das sieht ja sehr
schön aus aber das das ist das was
worauf er gerade so oh
rum ja das ist
es oh
ja das ist gut was ist eigentlich mit
dir da hinten
los ihr bringt mich um me Mittagsschlaf
tchen Nummer
4 also wirklich schön eingepackt wie so
ein kleines geschenktimmt salmon snack
for adult
cats so ein adult Cat würde ich sagen
ist auch ein Leckerli bei 4 bis 6 Kil 15
am Tag also ich habe das Gefühl die wird
schon mehr gute Sachen rausgesucht haben
die wird ja doch nichts hier reinmachen
mit viel Zucker oder n so wie ich das
jetzt gerade ist das eigentlich voll
okay h wird gegönnt
Leute aus der Hand ihr müsst so das
einmal durchbrechen und klein machen das
ist ja zu groß oh mein Gott kleine
Snacks nicht mein mein Taum ist das
nicht also er frisst eigentlich auch
nicht aus der Hand mein Gott diese
Prinzess zu groß zu groß ja aber hier
ist auch ein
kleines ach ja das konn sie jetzt ne ist
aus Mund gefallen oh guck mal hier ist
potato drin
ja das ist ein tolle sachenchen Nummer 5
ja also ich bin schwer
begeistert was hast du dazu zu
sagen nein
Edgar Cooper Katze also okay Cat klar du
brauchst viel für deine Katze aber ich
habe irgendwie erwartet dass noch mehr
für dich da drin ist aber wir sind erst
Türchen F also das ist Futter das ist
auch keine schlechte Marke ich bin jetzt
auch nicht so da in dem Game aber ich
Schlender schon gerne mal durch die
bekannten Futterhäuser und guck mir das
an Futter ist halt immer so eine Sache
er bekommt hypoallergenes Futter und sui
bekommt es einfach weil sie hier wohnt
deswegen würde ich vielleicht auch
vielleicht dem tierh Spenden oder so ja
also ist es nicht was du jetzt so
spontan einfach geben würdest nee da W
mir die durchfallgefahr zu groß und ist
es dann auch nicht bei vielen
Katzenbesitzern so dass du Katzenfutter
halt schwierig ist weil jeder hat ja
sich irgendwie auf etwas schon
eingestellt ja aber Abwechslung ist nie
verkehrt und eine Katze zu haben die auf
huhallergisch ist es halt schon
problematisch in der Hinsicht das in
vielen Futtersorten einfach huh mit dr
tüchen Nummer 6 es ist Nikolaus und wir
gehen an unseren katm Adventskalender
machen das tühchen auf da gibt was für
die CAT m ich freue
mich
m ja Nein schöne Farbe aber oh das mir
auch glitzert ach eigentlich ganz süß
weiter geht's ach so wie findest du das
Türchen Nummer se das muss ja top
gefüllt sein
ne entsprchend D ja ich finde das Design
also glitzermiau hätte nicht sein müssen
man hätte glaub ich ein bisschen cooler
gestalten können den klaut er sich jetzt
vielleicht dann packen wir ih mal bei
dir H tchen 7 muss zwar nicht top
gefüllt sein aber wir sind gespannt
fühlst du dich als katman bis jetzt
abgeholt ja ich find es eigentlich g
spannend also ich find es bis jetzt ganz
süß aha guck mal hier kannst du dich
gleich informieren was du da deinen
Katzen fütterst toll
und hier haben wir Hühnerherzen
Hühnerherzen getrocknete Hühnerherzen
guck mal der hat auch schon wieder Bock
der lecker sein Kü glaub ich muss das
auch noch mal revidieren so ich fütter
ihm kein huh er ist hypoallergen so
schlimm ist er nicht aber wir haben da
so unsere Problematiken so Susi bitte
schön fretrocknet findet sie eigentlich
immer gut ja es scheint Tür Nummer 8 in
tüche Nummer 8 sag was jetzt drin ist
kann ich lesen
ah das kennst du nicht das ist was für
Menschen liebe
ich tolles Design ne finde ich finde ich
süß kann man machen Türchen Nummer ne
Türchen Nummer ist das beste Türchen
denn das ist meine
Lieblingszahl silter Salatdressing hä UI
mhm ja das das ist so ein bisschen unter
umstritten das ist so eine katsp und das
soll smooie ach ein schoothie na klar
Muskelfleisch ja kann man machen das ist
aber auch so ein bisschen unnötig weil
eigentlich hatatzen trinken eh wenig und
wenn du den dann noch beibringst dass
dein trinken immer Geschmack hat so aber
das ist meine Meinung meine Meinung lieb
wie du immer so
vorsichtig die katzencommunity die ist
hart oh stimmt stimmt auf
fragdkatze.com keine Ahnung wie die
Blogs heißen manchmal hält man sich da
auf daran habe ich ja noch gar nicht
gedacht alle Aussagen die du tätigst
werden ja auseinander issen das stimmt
gar nicht meiner trinkt das super gut
und trinkt auch gut Wasser trinkt auch
super Wasser su z.B gar nicht wenn Du
möchtest können wir es ausprobieren es
ist ja nur zum
Testen innerhalb von D Tagen verfüttern
na das wird ja ein festschmaau für dich
danach trinkt er nur noch das num ach so
kurzes Review kurz noch dazu
[Applaus]
okay das ist verrückt ne wir haben hier
so kleine plastikspiralen das liebt doch
jede Katze bist du
bereit
wow Nummer 11 oh Lucky loose mh chicken
Cubes oh die sind weich sehr
hudenlasstig ja das stimmt designmäßig
sind die alle ganz schön weit vorne ne
ja du musst ja halt auch so die
klassische Cat mom vorstellen so die
gibt's ja von bis und ich meine stell
dir mal vor sowas lächelt D an im Regal
made in Switzerland an Nummer 12 was
heißt das wir sind bei der Hälfte
Halbzeit ist so ein chaotisches Video
aber es darf auch mal sein oder
[Musik]
ja in tüche Nummer 12 gibt es schon
wieder
snos ist das eine hundfote oder eine
katzenfote na ja eine katzenfote sieht
auch durchaus so aus aber ja doch kann
auch eine katzenfote sein wir sind
wieder beim Beig Thema mit dieser klein
bchen kze rie nich ist ein bisschen we
also na ja also sie ist hübsch ist ist
süß das ist ein Gadget glaube ich das
findet man im Kalender gerne
mal ich bin nicht enttäuscht
13 s Chicky Mickis tails und Tails
glaube das sind auch leckerl geeignet
als Einzelfuttermittel als Belohnung
oder mehrmals tglich wollen wir eins
probieren machen rie nach Hundefutter ja
so machen muss
so Bruder muss man jetzt sagen
durchgefallen weil sie nicht verrückt
danach sind Nummer
14 cool was ist das ich weiß es
nicht das leckmatte natürlich diese
lemte katzenchen findest du das kannst
du gut gebrauchen ich hatte SAS noch nie
also wird das glaub ich echt fantastisch
finden ich kenne das tatsächlich nur für
Hunde und für Hunde ist es halt viel
größer das heißt die beschäftigen sich
weil es alles in diese Rillen reingeht
und dann lecken sie sich da aber bei R
kann ich mir auch vorstellen dass i das
irgendwann langweilen wird also weil er
ja warum soll er für seine leckerles
Arbeiten ja oder unter Futterschale kann
man ja auch ja stimmt 15 die gönnen das
ist ja die gleiche ah cool aber jetzt
hast du die schleckmatte bekommen und im
nächsten Türchen gibt dann für die kann
man das auch oh sehr gut genau hier
haben wir einmal eine multivitaminpaste
wenn ich mich nicht irre und und eine
relaxpaste bei der relaxpaste bin ich
ganz
gespannt bei Rumo hat immer so ein
bisschen Probleme mit fremden Menschen
in unserer Wohnung und greift dann gerne
mal Füße
aness hat sich jetzt Dr gewöhnt die
bringt ja auch immer tolle Sachen mit
unterstützt Entspannung und Wohlbefinden
in besonderen Situation
16 jetzt geht das nämlich los oh wir
haben wieder ein Kissen mit fot also
hier gibt kurze Optik ist ganz okay ist
schon wieder eine Hundepfote obwohl ne
das sieht wie Katzen Katzen ja weiß ich
nicht kannst du irgendwas sagen dazu es
entspannt mich ich bin
high was sagst du zu dem Snake von
vorhin das dauert lange bis sie den ist
ne ich habe i gerade klein gemacht wird
Licht im Karton 17 inüchen Nummer 17 oh
granadaapad ich mag die Marke Sinfonie
Nummer 3 genau die haben irgendwie so
also die heißen granataer und da sind so
Granatapfelkerne drin mit Taurin und
Katzenminze und was ist das Strauß das
ist ein richtiges Futter mit
Füllung die 18 ist laut na was haben wir
denn in der 18 das war für
Susi m
nicht es ist irgendwie süß aber die
Perlen z.B also die Katze sitzt nicht
hier und sagt 1
2 Glocke Glocke
VI se
mi
Riesengarnelen Riesengarnelen miam ist
einer eigentlich meiner liebsten Sorten
aber die sind echt schuer also ist es
dann jetzt eine ganze
Garnele eine ganze Garnele dafür du
sagst die sind bisschen teuer ne aber
die also von der Verpackung vom Design
und von der Verpackung hier wirkt das
alles sehr
billig
was hat jetzt auseinander das hier eine
gefrier getrocknete Garnele leute das
ist
krass denkt s so ich würde so gern aber
ich weiß nicht wie man große Sachen
ist komm das schaffst du Susi was sagst
du ten out 10 ich liebe riesenkanelen
Nummer
20 der Kalender ist ja wirklich nett
gemacht ne Cat Lover Cat Lover Cat Lover
was bist du
Cat 21 was ist das denn biologischer
Geruchsentferner guck an gegen Hunde und
Katzurin so alle so wie alle Tiergerüche
ja das ist glaube ich etwas was man auf
jeden Fall in jedem Katzenhaushalt
gebrauchen kann Rumo hatte zweimal eine
blasenenzündung und Katzen sind sehr
sauber wir haben gar keine Probleme aber
mit der Blasenentzündung hat er halt
einfach gepiecht wenn er gepiecht hat
das ist ein bisschen wie fibres wow
frisch
22 natürlich darf das in einem
Adventskalender nicht fehlen ja ich die
oh oh was ist das für ein Henkel was ist
das für ein Loch im Henkel oh das ist
schon die billigste Tasse die es gibt ne
ich werde jetzt mit meiner miautasse und
meinem miauhut und meinem kettover
BH jeden Morgen verbringen also ich
finde sie so an sich ganz schön aber der
Henkel ist nicht so ja aber auch guck
mal wenn du jetzt trinkst dann steht
halt nicht vorne ja wen interessiert das
also stell dir mal vor ich würde wie so
ein Freak in so einem K sitzen
Mia
Türchen 23 vorletztes
Türchen das kriegst du hier
ganzepflegespray bessere kämbarkeit wir
halten es zusammen
fest so viele Hände gerade natürliche
Inhaltsstoffe für glänzendes Fell und
bessere kennbarkeit aber sind Katzen
nicht dafür bekannt dass sie sich selber
perfekt aber für ein Hund ist es auch
für Hunde ja ja für Katzen sehe ich auch
nicht so der kleine der Mann sitzt hier
auch zwischen dem Müll
Plastik ich reibe mich an
dir schönes
Plastik ach da waren die Kissen drin
deswegen ach so es ist Weihnachten wir
öffnen das 24 Türchen von unserem Cat
Adventskalender wow m sage ich dazu ich
meine du bist schon obsessed Cat m ne
obwohl ich finde die Tasche ohne scheiße
ich bin ja schon seit langer langer Zeit
auf der Suche nach einer schwarzen
einfachen Tasche das ist doch gut oder
also willst du nicht tragen nee ich
glaube ich die Mütze damit würde ich den
Postboten wahrscheinlich aber das kann
ich nicht draußen tragen ja ich finde
die Tasche an sich super cute das miau
macht irgendwie kaputt vielleicht weißt
was süßer ist wenn hier so z.B so kleine
Katzenohren oder so gewesen wären so
ganz unauffällig einfach so eine ganz
kleine Katze wie wie hier so das hier
halt in Klein in Gold weißt du so das
wäre dann einfach nur so
so wir wissen nicht warum es gibt hier
noch ein extra Paket die haben
vielleicht einfach lustig wenn einfach
eins doppelt reingemacht haben u die
haben mit gimcat irgendwie ein
Kollaboration dents dents oral also das
gibt einfach noch mal so als Extra oben
drauf ich glaube die hatten einfach zu
viel was sagst du zu dem Adventskalender
ganz schnell insgesamt finde ich den
wirklich cute da sind so Sachen bei ja
das das hatte ich noch nicht das kenne
ich nicht ich glaube RO und Susi werden
sich sehr darüber freuen sehr viele
Snacks halten halt super lange deswegen
ist es ganz cool ich würde jetzt auch
nicht alle aufmachen ich verteile das
jetzt an die Nachbarn und Freunde aber
so insgesamt 200 € ich meine kommt schon
ich bin fast
m also ja irgendwie süß gedacht auf
jeden Fall die Sachen für die Katzen
finde ich super also sorry aber die
Spielangel da gibt's auch bestimmt
bessere aber ich meine die fanden das
super ja es ist es ist auf jeden Fall
viel dabei und die so Keksausstecher so
super cute Keks also auch die Verpackung
an sich super cute nur das Problem ist
halt wirklich wenn den dann irgendein
Snack nicht schmeckt oder so und sie den
nicht essen dann hast du halt einen
ganzen Katzensnack oder allergisch gegen
Huhn das ist natürlich wirklich ich aber
da ich glaub da guckt man ja auch
vielleicht ich meine ich habe nicht auf
die Website geguckt also die Sachen für
die Katzen okay da gibt's bestimmt auch
bessere ich glaub so so paar Bälle oder
so hätten h noch irgendwie drin sein
irgendwas mehr zum Spiel aber die
Designs von den Artikeln für die catmom
die sind halt nicht so geil und dieser
Kalender ist ein Cat mom Adventskalender
da hätte man vielleicht sich gefreut
aber es ist halt auch eine
Geschmackssache es gibt bestimmt Leute
die CAT Lover und miau auf der
Handtasche ganz toll finden deswegen
muss man das halt immer für sich selber
wissen aber 200 € ist schon stabiler
Preis also 200 € i don't know wer das so
übrig hat die catcam ist ganz süß ja es
gibt jetzt als Abschied okay Leute bis
dann danke fürs zuschauen lasst ein Like
da bye und abonnieren nicht vergessen